اهلا وسهلا بكم في هذه الجوله الاسبوعيه
عبر المجلات ونبداها من هنا من فرنسا وهذا
الحديث الطويل الطويل عن ام المعارك كما
تسمى هنا معركه اصلاح نظام التقاعد وهذه
المواجهه مواجهه الشارع والحكومه حول هذه
الاصلاحات تتحدث عن هذه النقابات التي
تمضي وتزعم المضي قدما في الدفاع عن مكاسب
عقود طويله من النضال العمالي في فرنسا
وفي بوليتيس هذا النداء يوقعه 100 مثقف
وفنان للقول الله لهذه المنظومه الملحفه
في حق الذين يعملون في همم اذا في مهن
صعبه جدا وفي لمنه مجازين هذه الاولى لمن
يتم القريبه من الحزب الشيوعي هذه الاولى
التي تستعد الثوره الفرنسيه وتصور الرئيس
ماكها على برج لبسي لبسته حيث انطلقت
الثوره الفرنسيه وتكتب ما تكوند
كلمه معناها اذا عليه ان يتراجع وكلمه
غدخت معناها ايضا منظومه التقاعد معناها
التقاعد فبالتالي هناك اللاعب على الكلام
اذا وتهديد صريح للرئيس الفرنسي لهذه
الاصلاحات الحكوميه غير الشعبيه في مجالات
هذا الاسبوع حديث عن اوكرانيا الحرب تدخل
من عطفا جديدا وتصبحوا جاخ توتال حربا
شامله كما تكتب اذا المجله التي تقول
بانها حرب شامله لان الاستراتيجيات تغيرت
هناك استراتيجيه لك همم اذا القصف
العشوائي وذاك المواقع المدنيه والارهاب
للمدنيين وايضا لان مرتزقه فاجنر دخلوا
على الخط باغي ماتش تصور بورتريه لهذا
الرجل طباخ بوتين السابق الذي تحول الى
اميري حرب وهو زعيم مرتزقه فاجنر اسمه
بروج ولا دي اصبح نافذا جدا وفاحشه ثراء
كما تكتب اذا مجله سوسيتي بدورها وتقول
بانه قد يلعب دورا مهما في روسيا المستقبل
وذلك لا ينبا باي خير وتذكر مجله سوسايتي
بان فاجنر هي منظمه اقتصاديه تتاجروا
بالموت كما تكتب
وفي هذه المجالات ايضا حديث عن تركيا
اردوغان التي تلعب على اكثر من وتر وتزود
تركيا العضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي تزود
روسيا بقنابل كلوستر كما تسميها همم اذا
وتدخل على الحرب في اوكرانيا وفي هذا
الصدد تتحدث في حول روس تركيا دائما تتحدث
عن اردوغان الذي يطبق قبضته على تركيا
تركيا التي تتحول الى امبراطوريه
اردوغانيه او اماره وتنزلق نحو
الديكتاتوريه كما تعاني من ذيكونست في
غلافها لاكسبريس تتحدث عن هذا المازق الذي
يجدوا ببنت ياهو نفسه موضوعا في حيث انه
بال في نفس الوقت يتلقى ضغوطا من خلفائه
لمساعده او ارسال اسلحه الى اوكرانيا وفي
الوقت نفسه لا يريد ان يزعج روسيا اللاعب
المهم والاهم في الشرق الاوسط خاصه في ظل
ما يسميه اذا ببنه الخطر وتهديد الايراني
عن ايران تتحدثون في عددي هذا الاسبوع عن
العطب في العلاقه الايرانيه الفرنسيه
لماذا تستهدف ايران فرنسا وترجع المجله
الى اكثر من سبب لتازم هذا العلاقات الان
وفي التاريخ القريب ايضا في مجالات هذا
الاسبوع ايضا حديث في لوبس عن كتاب مهم
كتاب صدر مؤخرا حول اذا ما يسمى
الامبراطوريه بخسه الثمن للكاتب دوني
كانيو ويتحدث عن الاقتصاد في زمن
الاستعمار الفرنسي وكيف طورت فرنسا
الاستعماريه منظومه اقتصاديه تجعل من
خلالها المستعمرات تموله الاستعمار وذلك
يثير اذا الكثير من التساؤلات في ظل هذه
الدراسات الجديده بالاهتمام كما تكتب
المجله في مغيان حديثا عن قضيه
تقلب الراي العام وهي هذه السيده والتي
تسمى جان بن زكان وهي سيده همم اذا
بلجيكيه اسرائيليه تدعي بانها الابنه غير
الشرعيه للملك الحسن الثاني وهي ادعت
قضائيا في بلجيكا لتطلب فحصا ريبيا وتثبت
بانها اخت غير الشقيقه للملك محمد السادس
بيقول بانها عمليه احتيال والمجله تعلق
بان هذه القضيه ستتخذ حربا قضائيه
واعلاميه شكل حرب قضائيه واعلاميه في
لفيغو حديث عن نظريه المؤامره التي تعود
من جديد مع الكشف عن الارشيف حول اغتيال
الرئيس الاسبق كينيدي وترجح المجله
النظريه الدوله العميقه التي قد تكون لها
يد في الموضوع نظرا للقرائن التي تم الكشف
عنها في سوسيتي مجازين حديثا عن هذه الفئه
الغريبه من البشر هؤلاء المتفائلون
المستبشرون في ازمه في زمن الازمات كيف
لهم ذلك تتساءل المجله وفي ثاني مجازين
حديثا عن فوائد الصمت وعدم الكلام الكثير
لان الصمت اذن او القله في الكلام تحمل
معها الكثير من النفوذ والقوه لس حال
المجله تقول اذا كان الكلام من فضه فان
الصمت من ذهب شكرا جزيلا لكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]